depuis le hashtag lundi 14 septembre par
lequel des collégiens et des lycéens
revendiquer le droit de s'habiller comme
ils le souhaitent
on est entré dans un débat houleux et
sans fin sur la manière dont il faudrait
être vêtu à l'école le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer a tenté il ya quelques jours de
mettre fin à la discussion en déclarant
il est important d'arriver à l'école
dans une tenue correcte cela relève du
bon sens
l'école n'est pas un lieu comme les
autres vous n'allez pas à l'école comme
vous allez à la plage ou en boîte de
nuit
chacun peut comprendre qu'on vient à
l'école habillée d'une façon
républicaine
oui bonjour excusez moi de vous déranger
j'aimerais connaître la définition de
tenues républicaine s'il vous plaît ah
bon d'accord d'accord merci au revoir
il n'y en a pas bah oui on n'a pas en
réalité chaque établissement scolaire à
son propre règlement intérieur dans
lequel la question de la tenue peut être
abordé en france il n'existe aucun texte
national qui donne une définition
précise et fixe les règles à part les
lois de 2004 et 2010 qui interdisent de
manifesté ostensiblement dans un
établissement laïc une appartenance
religieuse comme portait le voile la
kippa ou une croix en pendentif
le ministère a tenté de calmer le jeu en
précisant que l'expression de jean
michel blanquer sur la tenue
républicaine ne sous-entend des pas que
ce sont les vêtements qui sont
républicains mais que c'est l'école qui
est républicaine évidemment aussitôt sur
twitter c'est la récréation
gamaty
mais alors s'il n'existe aucune
définition concrète comment est ce qu'on
fait en suisse par exemple une
information a récemment fait polémique
parce qu'un établissement scolaire
oblige les élèves dont les tenues sont
jugées inadéquates apporter un long tee
shirt xxl sur lequel il est écrit j'ai
une tenue adéquate
ajoutez à cela des témoignages
hallucinant de collégiennes qui
racontent que leurs professeurs leur a
dit que leur tenue un crop top un pull
col roulé qui laisse apparaître le
nombril déconcentre les garçons et on
nage en plein puritanisme et sexisme il
semblerait que le gouvernement et
certains professeurs et chefs
d'établissement être oublié que
l'adolescence est un match particulier
plus ils vont donner des directives aux
élèves assieds toi la victoire comme ça
va là bas moi ils auront de chance
d'établir ne serait ce qu'une once de
communication avec eux ce n'est pas un
sujet spécifiquement pour les filles
par exemple on ne vient pas au collège
en short
sauf pour faire de l'éducation physique
et sportive mais surtout quand il fait
38 degrés à la mi septembre
on doit faire attention à
l'hypersexualisation qui est une
pression sur nos enfants et adolescents
le vêtement ne doit pas être un facteur
ni de discrimination ni de
stigmatisation alors oui dans les faits
on est d'accord mais en interpellant
publiquement une collégienne de 12 ans
parce qu'elle porte un vêtement qui
laisse apercevoir son nombril en lui
expliquant que cela va des concentrés
son camarade de classe n'est ce pas
hyper sexualisée la question à la quelle
époque pour être en vie comme on dit sur
les réseaux sociaux